[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le journal de tv soixante
dix huit pour un point sur l'actualité
locale bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
tout de suite les titres de ce jeudi à 5
septembre elle été marquée par des
épisodes de canicules et de sécheresses
qui ont forcément impacter les cultures
quel bilan dresses les agriculteurs
reportage à plaisir éléments de réponse
en plateau quentin le guillou président
des jeunes agriculteurs de houdan est
notre invité ce week-end de nombreux
forums d'associations se déroule dans
les yvelines l'occasion notamment pour
les sections de football féminin de
tester leur popularité quelques mois
après la coupe du monde en france nous
recevons mireille lafond président du
club présidente du club d'elancourt
enfin après une semaine de rentrée c'est
l'heure de décompresser à la fin de
cette édition notre sélection des idées
de sorties à faire ce week-end sur le
territoire
mais avant de développer ses titres
quatre villes des yvelines de vienne
cité éducative ce label a été lancé
officiellement aujourd'hui par le
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
julien de normandie et son homologue à
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
l objectif lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire en intensifiant la prise en
charge des élèves pendant et après la
classe notamment par des activités
culturelles et sportives
vous le voyez sur le territoire font
partie du dispositif trappe chanteloup
les vignes et les mureaux ou encore
mantes la jolie
avec moi en plateau quentin le guillou
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes céréaliers
président des jeunes agriculteurs du
canton de houdan avec vous on va parler
du festival de la terre qui se tient ce
week end à mairie mais on va d'abord
dressé un bilan de l'agriculture de cet
été dans les yvelines dans le canton de
houdan le thermomètre est monté dans le
département jusqu'à 42 degrés et les
yvelines a reconnu un des épisodes
caniculaires et de sécheresse le préfet
a placé le département en situation
d'alerté le 23 juillet arrêté maintenu
le 21 août dernier
une situation qui a forcément impacter
le monde agricole reportage à plaisir de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de mélanie
poker ils scrutent le ciel et son
téléphone et jérôme regnault suit deux à
trois fois par jour l'évolution de la
météo c'est l'intérêt plus dur là en
effet on va se poser la question de
sortir les chats rude pour ce céréalier
c'est demain que les conséquences de la
sécheresse estivales vont se faire
sentir
l'exploitation arrive en période de
labour de préparation des terres pour
les semis l'an passé on était dans des
conditions encore plus difficiles où
l'aca mais vraiment impacté les levées
de colza là on est encore tôt dans la
saison donc il est encore temps que la
pluie arrive et que les potentiels soit
soit là elle les orages du début du mois
d'août n'ont pas changé la situation les
yvelines ont été placés en situation
dallaire sécheresse le 23 juillet par la
préfecture
mais tout n'est pas négatif pour cet
agriculteur l'a pas eu trop d'impact sur
les cultures d'automne
et donc sur le résultat de la moisson en
ça a été bon à très bon pour les
céréales c'est à dire et en quantité et
en qualité
les gras été formé au moment où la
sécheresse et est arrivée la canicule de
fin juin ça a été beaucoup plus
ordinaire à catastrophiques sur les
colzas qui eux avaient subi la
sécheresse de l'été 2018 le mail ça va
être particulier en effet puisqu'il a
pris lui le coup de chaud au moment où
il aurait dû être au pouvoir même
commencé ses floraisons donc lui le maïs
qui sera récolté entre dans la région
c'est souvent entre mi et fin octobre
on va jusqu'à fin novembre mais souvent
mi et fin octobre lui se porte plutôt
mal géré en breniaux exploitent 300
hectares de terrains où il cultive
principalement des céréales la pluie est
annoncée pour la fin de semaine avec de
rares averses
on l'a vu dans ce sujet quentin guillou
le guillou un bilan qui n'est pas
forcément le même en fonction des
produits récoltés comment s'est déroulé
l'été pour vous et pour les agriculteurs
du canton de houdan tout à fait donc ça
a été très dur pour pour tout le monde
une année très sèche il ya des cultures
qu'on était beaucoup plus impacté que
d'autres comme on a pu voir là là on
attend vraiment le maïs qui lui a été
fortement impacté sur le sec qui a eu
durant l'été qui a toujours aujourd'hui
c'est des sécheresses qui ont tendance à
se répéter
d'année en année ce que c'est une année
particulièrement catastrophique on a
déjà connu ça l'année dernière
là c'est la deuxième année cette année
on a eu la chance un petit peu sur les
cultures d'hiver donc comme le blé
maintenant le colza il a fortement subi
mais ouais ça devient très répétitif est
ce qu'on a déjà une idée des pertes que
cela va engendrer su colza ces moitiés
de production sur toute la france le blé
en est sur une production à peu près
moyenne le colza on attend maintenant
on a des premiers ressentis qui pourrait
très faible est ce que vous êtes aussi
vigilant sur la météo des prochains
jours un début septembre six où il n'y a
pas beaucoup de pluie tout à fait tout à
fait on a semé les colzas pour l'année
prochaine est déjà aujourd'hui ça
commence très très mal parce que aucun
colza ne sont levés ça fait déjà quinze
jours qu'ils sont en terre et ça ne lève
pas ça ne pousse pas donc ça laisse déjà
pressentir de mauvaises nouvelles pour
la suite alors ça a été l'une des
mesures pour faire face à la sécheresse
le ministre est le ministre de
l'agriculture a autorisé l'exploitation
de terres en jachère les agriculteurs
peuvent depuis le 21 ou demander une
autorisation pour couper les fourrages
afin de nourrir le bétail certains ont
critiqué une décision trop tardive
c'est aussi votre bien sûr au 21 août
c'est une décision qui aurait dû être
prise au mois de juin dès le mois de
juin dans fin juin début juillet arrivée
au 21 août
on a pu le voir pour particulier dans
nos dans nos gazons sur chez nous les
revêche
donc c'est pareil on va pas donner de
l'airbus sèche à des bovins du bétail là
honnêtement aujourd'hui
la mesure a été mise beaucoup trop tard
non une autre mesure dont tu as fait par
le ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume il va autoriser en tout cas
mettre en place prochainement ce qu'on
appelle des retenues d'eau une
soixantaine sur le territoire français
pour faire face à à deux prochains
épisodes
c'est une décision que vous accueillez
commencé mise en place nécessaire c'est
renaud et d'auto fait tout à fait il
faut il faut il ya des secteurs où ils
sont en pénurie ou l'irrigation ray
impossible aujourd'hui on a une quantité
d'eau qui tombe par périodes dans
l'année forte de plus en plus et avec le
changement climatique ça va s'accentuer
aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable de
retenir cette eau on la laisse partir à
la mer donc il faut qu'on puisse réussir
à la retenir elle a utilisé le reste de
l'année
quand on attirer ces périodes de 2 sec
justement du coup avec cette période
difficile la queue qui a précédé quelles
sont les perspectives pour vous dans les
prochains mois pour vous pour les
agriculteurs on attend la vue
aujourd'hui on est vraiment orienté les
yeux au ciel pour regarder la pluie
maintenant on peut-être des mesures on
va voir ce que l'état va nous proposer
sur les sur les mois à venir si on a de
nouvelles normes ou autre pour l'instant
on attend
vous allez être vigilant sur le sujet
resté avec nous quand un le guillou
actualité aussi heureuse pour vous c'est
ce 66e festival est de la terre que vous
organisez ce week-end à méré on en parle
tout à l'heure dans ce journal
six cent mille participants chaque année
à la fête de l'humanité elle revient le
13 du 13 au 15 septembre trois jours de
fête musique et des bas à la courneuve
pour s'y rendre et des bus seront mises
en place depuis la gare de la verrière
et c'est depuis ce lieu que la section
locale du parti communiste a commencé
aujourd'hui la vente des bons de soutien
pour l'événement est les propos sont
recueillis par marylène iapichino et
patrick jacques de dixmude l'objet qui
que ce soit c'est de vendre des
vignettes et c'est de diffuser les
horaires des gars on a des cars qui vont
partir le samedi matin et le dimanche
matin de la gare de la verrière et du de
la rue danielle casanova à trappes
c'est un exercice mise en place depuis
l'année dernière une fois par mois les
et sénateur des yvelines vont à la
rencontre des territoires après
rambouillet saint germain en laye ou
encore toussus-le-noble c'était au tour
de saint quentin en yvelines cet été
rencontres avec les entreprises
implantées sur le territoire comme
bouygues construction mélanie poquet et
michael et demi d'euros piloté à
distance les infrastructures routières
l'éclairage urbain une installation
actuellement en cours dans la communauté
urbaine du grand dijon développé par
bouygues des innovations au coeur d'une
visite des sénateurs yvelinois j'avais
envie de faire connaître encore mieux à
mes collègues de son entreprise de ce
territoire de co et bouygues
d'une part parce que ce sont des
entreprises familiales ensuite c'est
entendre 8 qui rayonne dans le monde
entier à travers ses entreprises
on a des exemples importants sur le
développement économique des impôts
portant sur la mobilité sur la
transition
wihr mental je pense que c'était deux
exemples importants
un virage vers les smart city ni pallier
le manque de médecins avec la
télémédecine des avancées technologiques
destinés notamment aux collectivités
l'origine c'est la volonté des
collectivités territoriales cette
volonté elle rencontre à savoir faire
d'une très grande entreprise qui en plus
est française et qui comprend les
collectivités territoriales parce que
que ce soit dans le domaine de la
construction ou de l'aménagement du
territoire à la cette expérience avec
les collectivités territoriales
ceux là ont rejoint un texte que nous
allons sans doute examiner ou en octobre
puis au printemps la loi notre adopté
définitivement le 7 août 2015 doit faire
l'objet d'un travail parlementaire
une réforme sur les collectivités
territoriales voulue par le gouvernement
cet été toujours la ferme desclaux
abonnés l'accueillait le rendez-vous des
agriculteurs d'île de france organisé
par le gap c'est le groupement des
agriculteurs biologiques pendant une
journée les différents acteurs ont pu se
rencontrer échanger aussi sur les bonnes
pratiques sur le thème de la
biodiversité retour sur cet événement
avec gwenaëlle sentiment apiculture
maraîchage élevage de volailles
bienvenue à la ferme des clots de bonnel
c'est ici que le groupement des
agriculteurs biologiques a rassemblé le
19 juin dernier les agriculteurs d'île
de france autour d'une thématique la
biodiversité
une journée d'information et de
rencontre entre les professionnels
agricoles
le but de la journée c'était de
rassembler les acteurs du territoire
pour parler du
problématique qui nous concerne tous et
qui était dernièrement soulevées par les
agriculteurs du gab
en considérant que bien méritée en bio
il y avait encore des efforts à faire au
niveau des aménagements pour favoriser
la biodiversité faunistique et
floristique sur leur exploitation
au programme de la journée visite de
terrain et présentation des aménagements
mis en place par la ferme des clos avec
l'appui aussi du parc naturel de
chevreuse plan des endroits protégés
création de points d'eau installation de
parcelles aménagées pour la faune
sauvage
tout est mis en oeuvre pour permettre
une régulation naturelle des
exploitations accueil de libellules et
plantes aquatiques arrivée d'insectes
pollinisateurs tout en protégeant les
exploitations des nuisibles et cerise
sur le gâteau les agriculteurs reçoivent
des indemnisations pour compenser les
surfaces non cultivées ou en ce moment
on est vraiment dans une période de
transition où les gens veulent changer
et cei et ce qui est intéressant c'est
sur certaines mesures on a des réponses
très positif de la biodiversité avec des
communautés d'espèces qui se
réinstallent très rapidement là on est
vraiment en phase d'installation ni dieu
projet donc notamment d'agroforesterie
cd des projets qui sont vraiment sur du
long terme quoi céder des projets qui
vont être mis en place sur plusieurs
dizaines d'années peut-être que moi j
enverrai pas le bout mais entre la mise
en place d'arbres fruitiers la mise en
place d'arbres bois d'oeuvre
effectivement c'est des projets qui
s'inscrivent sur du long terme et donc
ils vont prendre beaucoup de temps une
journée qui se termine par des ateliers
pédagogiques création de nichoirs pour
mésanges table ronde sur le thème les
insectes pollinisateurs et analyse de la
composition du sol
les organisateurs espèrent que les
agriculteurs pourront se servir de cette
rencontre et mettre en place des
aménagements de retour sur leur
exploitation
l'objectif à terme est de démultiplier
les bonnes pratiques avec des techniques
qui font leurs preuves sur le terrain et
qui s'avère plus saine pour
l'environnement et pour le consommateur
un autre événement ce week end à méré
les jeunes agriculteurs d'île de france
ouest organise la 66e édition et du
festival de la terre c'est ce samedi et
dimanche un moment pour découvrir sa
muse et comprendre le monde agricole et
pour en parler toujours avec mon plateau
quentin le guillou président des jeunes
agriculteurs du canton de houdan c'est
un événement qui se prépare depuis un an
j'imagine qu'à une certaine excitation à
deux jours du festival tout à fait tout
à fait là on va dire que ça fait une
semaine où on est vraiment on donne tout
ce qu'on peut là j'en viens justement et
puis je vais repartir après on est là
pour faire la plus belle fête et ça fait
un an qu'on y travaille
la plus belle fête sur le week-end sur
deux jours est-ce que tout est prêt ou
en tout cas tout sera prêt samedi matin
oui oui on va tout faire pour que samedi
matin soit ça soit ouvrait déjà le ce
soir on est très bien avancé on a encore
une très belle journée demain on a le
temps qui est avec nous donc normalement
un bon week-end vous parlais tout à
l'heure des difficultés traverse en ce
moment par la profession est ce que ce
genre d'événement est important aussi
pour sensibiliser le public rappelait la
nécessité de soutenir le monde agricole
qui nourrit la france tout à fait c'est
on organise ces événements là c'est
vraiment pour faire
santé le monde agricole et enfin un
échange entre agriculteurs citoyen
consommateur il y en a qui ont des
préjugés de ceux qui ont des
connaissances et on va échanger avec
tous les acteurs du monde agricole et
avec tous les citoyens le thème cette
année c'est l'agriculture d'hier et de
demain ça veut dire quoi l'agriculteur
il est il à ses traditions il compte sur
ses traditions mais regarde tout de même
vers l'avenir c'est ça que ça veut dire
tout à fait donc d'hier à demain c'est à
dire on va amener beaucoup de matériels
anciens qu'on aurait pu avoir dans nos
fermiers à 50 60 ans on va avoir du
matériel aussi d'aujourd'hui lui
matériel classique et d'innovation sur
peut-être ce qui pourrait être le
matériel de demain des robots désherbeur
les robots qui aurait peut-être
travailler à notre place dans les champs
ou faire des choses un peu plus délicate
que l'humain a du mal à faire les drones
aussi qui sont utilisés de plus en plus
dans les affaires les cultures
céréalières je crois oui tout à fait
pour la carto cartographier les
parcelles sur les exploitations pour
diminuer les applications d'intrants ou
les engrais alors il y aura son stand
présent qu'est-ce qu'on pourra voir sur
votre festival énormément de choses
c'est à dire tous les produits locaux
qu'on peut retrouver dans les yvelines
donc ça va des escargots
ça va
actuellement des lentilles plein de
choses qu'on pourrait retrouver dans les
yvelines
on va avoir des fous de troque donc food
truck avec aussi des produits locaux on
à monsieur christophe robin qui
agriculteurs à son chant qui vient
vendre ses poulets de qui produit sur sa
ferme
on va avoir aussi un gros gros stand de
boulangerie ca les boulangers
d'ile-de-france qui sont là sur les deux
jours qui font du pain en direct on est
en train de me la de fabriquer une
boulangerie en plein milieu d'un champ
en mer
et voilà donc la c1 l'an valorise
forcément le blé on l a fait tout proche
du territoire de la beauce tout à fait
on valorise du blé des yvelines d'île de
france
et puis les gens pour en acheter avant
de repartir bas leur pain chaud pour le
soir même ou le lendemain lui réussi un
concours bovin c'est la deuxième édition
de ce concours deuxième édition voilà du
concours bovins avec les bouchers d'île
de france la chambre d'agriculture en
partenariat où on va organiser un
concours bovin qui s'était perdue il ya
quelques années et qu'on est en train de
restaurer dans les yvelines quelles sont
vos attentes pour que 66e festival de la
terre soit une réussite pour une très
belle réussite c'est que une maximum de
personnes viennent nous voir viennent
discuter avec nous via l'échangé est
passé un très bon moment avec nous sur
le festival
durant ces deux jours et l'entrée de 5
euros gratuit pour les moins de 12 ans
ce festival de la terre je rappelle que
c'est ta mére ce samedi 10h 20h et
dimanche 10h 18h merci quentin le
guillou président des jeunes
agriculteurs et du canton de houdan on
retrouve bien sûr toutes les
informations sur la page facebook de
l'événement ce week-end le premier après
la rentrée c'est aussi
traditionnellement le moment des forums
des associations à saint quentin en
yvelines 12 communes organisent le
l'heure essentiellement samedi rendez
vous par exemple de 9h30 à 12h et de
13h30 à 17h30 au gymnase du moulin à
vent à coignières 10h 17h à la verrière
pour le forum de rentrée au gymnase de
la fraternité est même horaire à
maurepas qui organise son événement au
gymnase de la malmö
montigny le bretonneux lui elle cette
ville de montigny-le-bretonneux convie
ses habitants entre 9h30 et 16h au
centre sportif pierre de coubertin
ça se terminera aussi à 16h à villepreux
c'est au gymnase alain mimoun enfin
seule ville saint-quentinoise a proposé
son forum des associations dimanche est
les clayes-sous-bois divisera le
rendez-vous en trois lieux et vous
l'avez vu dans l'animation le forum
d'elancourt se tient lui à samedi de 9h
à 17h au complexe sportif de l'europe et
vous serez sur place mireille lacombe
ont soir non c'est grégory vous vous
êtes la présidente du club de football
d'elancourt l'eau et ses élans cours
merci à d'être avec nous en plateau
juste avant de parler foot féminin
puisque vous êtes venu à nous parler de
cette thématique
ce forum des associations c'est toujours
un rendez vous important pour votre club
incontournable de début de saison pour
toutes les associations de manière
générale mais pour nous il fait
effectivement c'est le c'est le gros
point elle est grosse les grosses
distributions dossier effectivement 300
400 personnes pas sur le site en
habituellement ça c'est l'occasion de
rencontrer vos bénévoles avoir des
informations sur les inscriptions pour
la prochaine saison et peut-être aussi
parler davantage de votre section
féminine qui a été créé il y a dix ans
au club avant l'été vous comptiez une
soixantaine de licenciés 60 je crois 62
précisément dans vos effectifs mais
entre temps il a eu cet événement
forcément la coupe du monde féminine de
foot qui s'est déroulé en plus sur le
territoire français est ce que ça a tiré
deux nouvelles joueuses depuis alors ça
a déjà attiré avant parce
qu'effectivement ça a été très
médiatisée on est déjà venu nous
rencontrer nous et les clubs aux
alentours on commençait déjà à sentir
effectivement ces jeunes filles qui
étaient atterrés par le foot
et puis ben alaoui cet été ça a commencé
à prendre un rythme et un petit peu
accéléré on est déjà aujourd'hui à plus
de 30% de deux licences en plus eu à la
même date à la même période
donc on espère effectivement que malade
et que la rentrée scolaire est fait est
que le forum va être lancé on va pouvoir
concrétiser ces chiffrés et avoir une
belle saison avec le foot féminin s'est
fait finalement cet engouement que vous
ressentez se poursuivre dans les
prochains mois que c'est servi à quelque
chose finalement cette coupe du monde en
france ont tout à fait tout à fait elle
a effectivement là cette semaine c'était
la reprise sur les u13 u15 f
on avait déjà 24 filles
avec une majorité qui était pas encore
inscrits du coup et je pense que ça va
être ressenti dans tous les clubs de
france j'espère parce que c'était
c'était le moment où il fallait
effectivement mettre un coup
d'accélérateur sur cette pratique
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire à votre avis
pour pas que l'engouement retombe dans
les prochains mois continuer à parler
diffusent est toujours à la télé ces
matches deux fusils le mipim est
effectivement bien mettre les bonnes
personnes au bon endroit bien
accompagner les filles bien les former
puisque bon la plupart du temps c'est
beaucoup quand même deux débutantes donc
mettre les bons éducateurs au bon
endroit
les accompagner à voir les parents qui
sont présents régulièrement et puis je
pense qu'après tout plus m toklas met en
route rapidement davantage de
féminisation aussi dans les postes de
dirigeants c'est le cas dans votre club
est à la tête d'un club de football
on est tout à fait alors c'est vrai que
c'est par c'est pas monnaie courante et
on est quatorze femmes sur sur les
yvelines donc c'est vrai que c'est une
grosse mission mais bon c'est plutôt
intéressant et effectivement elle en
cours on a je pense est spécifié
spécifications qui fait que voilà une
femme présidente il ya des femmes en
bureau des femmes dirigeantes il ya une
femme arbitre
il ya des femmes joueuses et des jeunes
filles qui commencent à mettre le pied à
l'étrier donc ouais c'est intéressant et
puis nos joues au seigneur commencé
effectivement envie d'avoir le don et la
capacité à pouvoir former les plus
jeunes donc je pense que c'est une belle
vitrine sur ce forum et samedi ce que
vous allez davantage parler de la
section féminine ou comme les autres
années ça fait dix ans qu'elle y fait
enfin ses mails moyen de fabs loin de
faire de différence justement s'est
montré effectivement que les filles
elles ont leur place autant que les
garçons et un club de foot c'est un club
qui accueille qui accueille tout le
monde
plus d'une soixantaine de licenciés on
le disait féminine ça se vit sur
plusieurs catégories
c'est ça tout à fait alors ça commence
dès des plus petites aux plus âgés donc
on part des 8,5
on a une section baby foot où on a déjà
quelques petites qui sont intéressés
donc ils viendront s'inscrire samedi et
après effectivement de lui si ça eu 11
cd féminine qui joue pas qu'il
s'entraîne une fois par semaine tout
seul et qui s'entraîne après en mixité
qui font des plateaux qu'organise le
district régulièrement
les week-ends avec d'autres clubs donc
elle commence à pratiquer entre filles
et donc là cette année effectivement on
a reçu le label école de foot féminin
l'année dernière donc on est structuré
pour accueillir et donc cette année on a
pu en avoir une et 13 f
une quinzaine funi 18 j'espère et puis
les seniors les seniors effectivement
qui vont être à andré puis à 7 aussi une
belle équipe un beau championnat l'année
dernière donc oui ça joue au ballon
si vous le dire dans ce journal ce qui
peut rare pourrait être intéressant
c'est d'avoir les filles dès les
catégories débutants tête voilà pouvoir
suivre une évolution suivre cette
évolution est la pérenniser les
conserver et puis vint les faire
progresser arriver jusqu'en seniors et
peut-être même un jour arriver dans les
mains de notre partenaire l' aj auxerre
qu'est ce qu'on vous souhaite pour cette
saison alors plus généralement pour le
club d'elancourt section féminine
section masculine également pas des
résultats
un des résultats effectivement là on est
en train de se restructurer on à
l'arrivée d'un directeur sportif
aziz mokaddem qui est arrivé cette année
voilà on a beaucoup d'ambition on espère
effectivement qu'on va pouvoir
concrétiser sur un an sur deux ans mais
oui l'accélérateur et demi ben bonne
saison avoue mercier à venir et la
présidente du club de football de l'eau
et celle en cours merci beaucoup
[Musique]
et j'accueille à présent on est content
de la retrouver mélanie poquet sur ce
plateau bon soir de la rédaction tv 78
quoi de mieux pour décompresser en cette
fin de semaine cette première semaine de
rentrée pour profiter de rendez vous
originaux mélanie vous avez sélectionné
deux rendez-vous deux idées de sorties à
faire ce week-end et oui et pour l'un
d'entre eux on va prendre de la hauteur
parce que le musée d'archéologie
nationale de saint germain en laye vous
propose une balade pour le moins
originale ou promenades historiques sur
les toits du château une hauteur qui
vous permet d'avoir un point de vue sur
la forêt les alentours jusqu'à l'aqueduc
de marly elles sont organisés tous les
mercredis samedis et dimanches jusqu'au
30 septembre et la réservation se fait
le jour même à la billetterie du musée
plus au sud dans le département dans le
parc naturel de la haute vallée de
chevreuse et une balade bucolique
oui c'est le musée du petit moulin qui
vous emmène là pour une randonnée de
trois heures un peu plus de 6 km pour
partir à la découverte du réseau
hydraulique des vaux de cernay à travers
six moulins à eau
certains ont bien sûr aujourd'hui
disparu mais on trouve encore quelques
traces et à l'issue de cette randonnée
le petit moulin de vaux de cernay sera
visite en accès libre pour les
intéressés pensez à réserver auprès du
petit moulin le rendez-vous grégory est
donné ce samedi 7 septembre à 14h30
merci mélanie on vous retrouvera dès la
semaine prochaine jeudi aux manettes de
l'émission c'est 8 culture cette saison
sur tv 78 autres idées de sorties le
ballet de l'opéra de paris
cendrillon qui est projeté en plein air
plusieurs projections de l'oeuvre du
chorégraphe noureev et dont la musique
est signée par prokofiev sont proposés
dans les yvelines ce samedi 7 septembre
à conflans sainte honorine versailles et
saint germain en laye et le samedi 14
septembre à mantes la jolie et marly le
roi s'est à chaque fois à 21h objectif
l'accès de la culture pour tous écouté
cette interview au micro de nicolas
landry
ce qui est très intéressante je trouve
c'est que et bien cendrillon n'est plus
la cendrillon que l'on a connu c'est à
dire des contes de fées des enfants mais
c'est une cendrillon qui a été reproché
repositionner dans les années 30 avec
comme si elle était une artiste dans ce
monde hollywoodien avec si tu veux si
vous voulez tout une espèce de
développement de sa vie
le cadre cinématographique avec des
rappels cinématographique donc c'est
très étonnant
il ya toute une histoire métaphorique
autour de cendrillon donc ça s'adresse à
la fois aussi bien aux enfants qu'aux
adultes puisque la démarche métaphorique
dans le monde cinématographique et va
nous permet d'avoir quelque chose de
très très original et puis d'une qualité
exceptionnelle
projection gratuite toutes les
informations à retrouver sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
avant de vous laisser attention si vous
empruntez la ligne e du transilien en
raison de travaux de maintenance
aucun train ne circulera ce samedi 7
septembre sur cet axe qui relie la
verrière à la défense à paris des bus de
substitution seront mis en place
uniquement sur certains tronçons toutes
les informations sur le site
transilien.com c'est la fin de cette
édition demain vous retrouvez marylène
iapichino pour le premier à 7,8 hebdo de
la saison qui reviendra sur l'essentiel
de l'actualité de cette semaine quant à
moi et je vous retrouve dès lundi pour
un journal d'information locale belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]